>> Jon: HELLO, FRIENDS. IT'S
HAPPENED AT LAST. WINTER'S
CHILL GREY HAS YIELDED TO
THE FULL WARMTH OF SPRING
THE NEW SEASON'S SEEDLINGS AWAKE
FROM THEIR SLUMBER AND BURST
THROUGH THE THAWING LOAM
BLOSSOMING IN GLORIOUS COLORS
AND RELEASING ANOTHER YEAR'S
BOUNTY OF POLLEN
WHICH WHILE IT IS NICE FOR
THE PLANTS, THREATENS TO
KILL US ALL!
>> ALLERGY EXPERTS THIS
MORNING ARE WARNING OF A
POLLEN TSUNAMI.
>> A POLLEN TSUNAMI IS SWEEPING
ACROSS MOST OF AMERICA RIGHT
NOW.
>> POLLEN TSUNAMI SUDDENLY
HITTING VERY HARD.
>> POLLEN TSUNAMI, SOUNDS
LIKE WE MADE IT UP.
>> Jon: NO!
(LAUGHTER)
NO, NO, POLLEN TSUNAMI,
DEFINITELY SOUNDS LIKE A
REAL SCIENTIFIC TERM.
AND INCREDIBLY APPROPRIATE
ONE COMPARING ITCHY EYES AND
SNEEZING TO NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT KILL HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS.
REALLY! I CHECKED IN A BOTANY
TEXTBOOK, POLLEN TSUNAMI.
RIGHT THERE IN THE GLOSSARY
NO, I DON'T EVEN NEED TO
CHECK IT I TRUST YOU, YOU ARE
THE NEWS.
ALTHOUGH I FEEL LIKE LAST
YEAR THEY GAVE ALLERGY
SEASON A DIFFERENT DISASTER
MOVIE NAME.
>> WE ARE DONE AND DONE WITH
THAT POLAR VORTEX FOR THIS
YEAR BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
POLLEN VORTEX.
>> WHAT SOMEWHERE NOW
CALLING THE POLLEN VORTEX.
>> THE POLLEN VORTEX IS
LAUNCHING AN ASSAULT.
>> YES, YES, YES.
POLLEN VORTEX OR AS IT IS
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO, THE
GARDEN.
(LAUGHTER)
SO SOMETIMES THE CREATIVE
DESCRIPTIONS OF ALLERGY
SEASON MISS THE MARK.
BUT ISN'T THAT WHY GOD
INVENTED CLICHES
>> ABOUT 40 MILLION AMERICAN
SUFFER FROM SEASONAL
ALLERGIES.
AND THIS SPRING THEY'RE
GETTING HIT WITH A PERFECT
STORM OF MISERY.
>> A PERFECT STORM FOR
ALLERGY SUFFERERS.
>> THE PERFECT STORM OF
ALLERGIES.
>> PERFECT STORM FOR ALLERGY
SUFFERERS.
>> THE PERFECT STORM, A LOT
OF SNOW, A LOT OF WATER AND
NOW A LOT OF WARM WEATHER,
PERFECT STORM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> IF IT HAPPENS EVERY YEAR
AT THE SAME TIME, THAT
DOESN'T REALLY COUNT AS A
PERFECT STORM, REALLY.
IT'S JUST A [BLEEP] STORM.
IN FACT THE ONLY THING
PERFECT HERE IS HOW
PREDICTABLE THE COVERAGE OF
POLLEN IS YEAR AFTER YEAR.
>> THIS SPRING IS SHAPING UP
TO BE THE WORSE ALLERGY
SEASON IN YEARS.
>> ONE OF THE WORST ALLERGY
SEASONS IN AREAS.
>> THE WORST ALLERGY SEASON
THAT WE HAVE EVER, EVER
SEEN.
>> ONE OF THE WORST ALLERGY
SEASONS ON RECORD.
>> ONE OF THE WORSE ALLERGY
SEASONS EVER.
SEASONS IN YEARS.
>> ALLERGY SEASON IS ALREADY
ONE OF THE WORST IN RECENT
MEMORIES.
>> THIS IS THE WORST ALLERGY
SEASON EVER.
>> ONE OF THE WORST ALLERGY
SEASONS IN YEARS.
>> THE WORST ALLERGY SEASON
IN A DECADE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> HOW CAN EVERY YEAR BE THE
WORST EVER.
WHAT, IS IT THE KNICKS?
00:02:59,613 --> 00:00:00,000
YEAH, BOO ME, I OWN THE TEAM.